[Music] Don't
get carried away
[Applause] It's
too late. It's so
noisy.
Friends protect their friends. People they like protect people they like.
And what's so annoying about it? It does
n't matter whether my dog ​​is God or not. I just
smile at everyone.  I just want it to stay on.
This light, the
sanctuary of that time.
God, I
protect everyone's smiles.
Why? [
Music] Please
lend me more power.
[Music]
I'm busy right now. It's terrible. It's terrible.
What happened?  I asked him if he was going to tell me
this, and he said, ``This is a secret,'' but I have to ask people to learn how to
distinguish between good and bad things.But
where do you find people like that?